bonjour d'un bug free dit merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
donald trump qui envoient des troupes
fédérales à portland donald trump qui
change d'avis sur le port du masque
stratégie électorale euh non c'est à
dire que le contexte de l'envoi de
troupes n'est pas tout à fait conformes
à ce qui vient d'être expliqué il ya un
certain nombre de villes américaines qui
sont en proie aujourd'hui à l'anarchie
depuis plusieurs semaines avec des
victimes civiles innocentes des femmes
des hommes et même des enfants les mères
démocrate de ces villes refusent de
faire intervenir la police et non
seulement refuse de faire intervenir la
police mais donne l'ordre de ne pas
intervenir et au delà de ça programme le
des financements donc l'abolition
finalement de la police dans leur ville
donc ça c'est le contexte même un
tantinet différent de ce qui vient
d'être expliqué alors par rapport à ça
il ya dans ces villes un certain nombre
de bâtiments qui sont fédéraux et c'est
non seulement le droit mais le devoir le
plus élémentaire du gouvernement fédéral
américain que d'assurer effectivement la
protection de ces bâtiments
vous venez d'évoquer du coup ce qui se
passe du côté de portant dans ma
première question il avait également
donald trump qui change
de fusil d'épaulé par rapport à la
stratégie du port du masque en lien avec
la pandémie de coronavirus qu'est-ce
qu'il faut interpréter même question
est-ce que c'est aussi une stratégie
électorale alors qu'il est en baisse
dans les sondages
je crois que ce sujet là est tout à fait
différent donc là on a affaire à cette
question du virus sur lequel a
aujourd'hui et quoi qu'on en est même
les plus grands experts dans le monde
notamment didier raoult nous explique
qu'on ne connaît pas encore le fin mot
de l'histoire
ce qui est certain c'est que
contrairement à ce qu'on lit souvent
dans la presse il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
dans aucun des pays concernés de
deuxième vague au sens strict les rues
question est de savoir si le vélo je
vais devenir saisonniers ou pas les
etats unis sont un très grand pays et
donc il ya une première phase dans
certaines parties des etats unis
maintenant il y à aix anciennement sud
et dans l'ouest
une deuxième phase plus aligné je dirais
sur le reste de l'amérique centrale
yémen du sud et donc effectivement à
l'heure actuelle personne ne peut
prétendre connaître le fin mot
l'histoire il y a disons le une forme de
l'amateurisme à certains égards dans la
gestion de cette crise par les
différents au gouvernement américain
qu'il n'y a pas seulement le
gouvernement fédéral est aussi tous les
états fédéraux et c'est d'abord en
réalité une compétence fait des heureux
on a retrouvé le même à ma curieuse et
souvent bien pire d'ailleurs dont la
plupart des pays d'europe occidentale et
il faut d'ailleurs rappeler à cet égard
que à l'heure actuelle au moment où nous
parlons
le nombre de morts dus que vides par
million d'habitants est très nettement
supérieure dans la plupart des pays
d'europe occidentale à ce qu'il est aux
etats unis donc cette façon nous avons
ici en europe de juger de la gestion par
les par les américains de cette fille me
paraît empreint d'une forme de sentiment
de supériorité morale qui n'est pas
justifiée par les faits et d'ici
l'élection du 3 novembre dans environ
100 jours qu'est ce qui peut se passer
selon vous les deux sujets dont nous
venons par l'ue vont intervenir je crois
dans la façon dont les les électeurs
américains vont finir par cristalliser
leur choix dans une direction ou dans
l'autre il y à un autre élément qui va
à venir c'est l'ampleur je dirais de la
reprise économique qui aura eu lieu
d'ici là à l'heure actuelle il ya un
certain nombre de signes qui sont plus
qu'encourageants puisque le nasdaq n'a
jamais été aussi élevé il a complètement
éliminer les pertes de la crise du cnid
et le dow jones a quasiment rap enfin
quelques centaines de points après
refait l'intégralité de ce qu'ils
avaient perdu donc ce sont là les signes
précurseurs d'une reprise économique
il faudra il faudra voir quel sera son
ampleur d'ici effectivement au jour de
l'élection
c'est à dire le droit devant et le
dernier facteur à mon avis important qui
va intervenir par rapport à cette
élection c'est évidemment que l'élection
se joue entre deux personnalités et donc
qui vient de ce train on voit à longueur
de médias avec une critique souvent ici
en europe occidentale mais il y a
également son opposant et son opposant
en force est de constater quand il se
livre à une intervention publique qu'il
est manifestement atteint d'un certain
nombre de difficultés je dirais qu'on
peut qualifier de sénilité ou de signes
précurseurs d'un affaiblissement de ses
capacités cognitives enfin quoiqu'il en
soit une faute aussi regarder
effectivement ce qui se passe dans
l'autre camp et il y aura trois débats
qui seront programmés entre les deux
candidats monsieur trump et monsieur
d'haydn qui seront évidemment décisif je
crois de la façon dont les électeurs
américains finiront par cristalliser
leur choix merci drieu godefridi d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur en philosophie et
auteur du livre
reload comment à l'américain vente le
siècle aux éditions tes skis